today we're talking about the planet
mercury the closest planet to the sun
and the smallest planet in our solar
system
actually it's smaller than some of the
moons in our solar system so it's
smaller than ganymede it's only a little
bit bigger than earth's moon itself
so a mercury year the time it takes for
mercury to go around the sun is 88 earth
days so if you lived on mercury you'd be
much older than you are on earth yeah
there's this very strange thing about
mercury um that it actually rotates very
slowly and so a day the time it takes
the planet to rotate once is very long
compared compared to a year and the time
it takes to actually go around the sun
and so uh a day
there's this strange effect that that
for every twice that you go around the
sun the planet rotates three times so
three days on mercury is the same as two
years and it's not just approximately
true it's exactly true it's exactly true
that it goes around exactly three times
rotates exactly three times for every
twice it orbits around the sun and this
is a phenomenon called resonance where
you have this matching up of things
exactly in integer numbers relating to
one another is a resonance
um it's the same kind of thing as with
the moon going around the earth that the
moon rotates exactly once it has a one
day for every year for every time it
goes around the earth which is why we
always see the same face of the moon
towards us but the case in mercury is
kind of a bit subtler
because it's not a one-to-one resonance
it's what's called a three to two
resonance it rotates three times for
every twice it goes around
so if you're standing on mercury you see
the sun in the sky for almost six months
as it rises really slowly then just
hangs out there and then moves down you
wouldn't have a blue sky because you
don't have any atmosphere to scatter the
photons but you would be able to see
distant stars so you'd have kind of a
nighttime sky but you'd still have
illumination from the sun so you'd still
be bright you'd still have a shadow you
just wouldn't have a blue sky like what
we saw when the men walked on the moon
yeah exactly like what we saw when the
men walked on the moon so the the basic
idea is that planets go around the sun
following ellipses something one of the
things that kepler figured out very long
time ago
but it's not quite true if you really
had a point like planet going around a
point like sun they would indeed follow
exactly ellipses but because planets
aren't exactly point-like and there are
other planets all perturbing their
orbits and so on they don't actually
follow exactly ellipses in about the
mid-1800s people were trying to map out
the orbits of planets based on newtonian
physics and we did very well predicting
the moon's orbit in mars as orbit and
venuses but mercury's for some reason
was a little strange it was um
off from what newtonian physics
predicted
and so this actually led people to
suggest that there might actually be
another planet that was perturbing the
orbit of mercury that was even closer to
the sun so people came up with the idea
that there was this planet called vulcan
even closer to the sun that was actually
causing it but then people searched for
this planet and couldn't find it
and it turned out that the answer was it
was general relativity because general
relativity says the laws of gravity
you've been using the newtonian laws of
gravity aren't quite right and when you
put in what's known as the
post-newtonian correction which is just
kind of starting to put general
relativity into the laws of gravity
you find actually you can explain all
this difference between the orbit you
actually see in the orbit you're
expecting to see so this was one of the
the very first pieces of actual evidence
for the validity of einstein's general
theory of relativity so what newton says
was happening is right but only in the
limit when gravity isn't very strong so
when there's very weak things going on
newtonian gravity is pretty much
spot on
what general relativity says is that
when gravity starts getting stronger
then you get further and further away
from that newtonian law of gravity and
so you're sufficient now with the with
the case of mercury gravity's starting
to get that little bit stronger because
the two are a bit closer together and so
you start seeing the very subtle first
effects of general relativity so
newtonian gravity is kind of a limit
that works
part of the time but general relativity
is kind of the big picture that works
all the time we've sent a couple
spacecraft to mercury the first one was
in the 70s it's called mariner 10 and it
did a couple orbits around and took
images and sent it back but actually
there was an entire side of mercury that
we weren't able to see with that
spacecraft so we recently nasa recently
sent another one called the messenger
and it took off in 2004 and it's been
traveling since then and just last year
it arrived so it's been doing a few
close passes around mercury and it will
eventually orbit in 2011. so through the
messenger we've been able to see really
high resolution images of all the crater
structures some of the craters when
these impactors come and they land on
the planet a lot of material gets shot
up and then it spreads these bright rays
around so we can see evidence for that
on mercury and there's
not any activity happening to erase
those effects
actually messenger
just saw evidence for volcan volcanic
activity on mercury mercury is very
close to the sun
always and it's very close to the sun in
our sky so whenever you try to look for
it it's always going to be very close to
to the sun so you can just see it right
before the sun sets or just
before the sun rises and so since it
passes around the sun very often it
passes in front of the sun which you can
only see with very fancy filters and
things like that but this is what we
call a transit when mercury actually
passes right in front of the sun
at night time on mercury the part of the
planet that is not facing the sun
when it's the farthest away from the sun
is actually very cold so it's minus 180
degrees celsius
and when the planet is the closest to
the sun
and the part that's facing the sun the
daytime part is actually very hot so
it's 430 degrees celsius do you want to
take that umbrella no i certainly
wouldn't need this umbrella if i went to
mercury there's no atmosphere no clouds
no anything that would cause me to not
have a nice day
they've been the heat yeah you might
want to use it to keep the sun off yeah
that's true